I better see ring hi my name is Shayla
esli and this is my mom monique athlete
I'm Cameron from LA this is my dad I'm
Ken Morris and this is my son what did
it only Son hi my name is Tim Howell and
this is my darling Darla and I'm here to
play this game that she told me about
all right never have I ever lied about
liking a gift you gave me
really women
I have not okay well you know yeah and
when y'all bought me that robe for
fathers like well how long ago was it
this is like you know four years ago but
you wore them I wore them because you
got it for me and that's what matters oh
come on baby yeah you gonna wear that
shirt never have I ever
sexy is that light that's the same is
that sexy really you got to have texting
when you cook because I happen to be
married right now we don't just go home
and just
but like knowledge being a woman luckily
like sometimes I was so terrified I'm
standing there with my hands up and I
just peed right there well it's it's
agus the police feel so so bad freakin
let us go they just told us they're
walking home you know as you get closer
to your destination your body
destruction
oh now you know just it goes but turned
up a little bit I forgot what it felt
like appealing yourself and I was like
what is that sensation like what is that
light that we were just talking about
another you know and I'm gonna do it
let me just experiment and you weren't
outside right right right
so you did it in the house oh never have
I ever watched porn do girls like what
is it free of the paper
oh my gosh they had a girlfriend and I
yeah
[Music]
unintentional anyway never have I ever
blacked out who are you well I'm sorry
blacked out like in fainted I think they
may like party you have I know I I got
that party Jean from you well when I
turned 21 which is that just happen I
went out and I was I drink too much and
I didn't realize cuz I didn't eat before
that was a problem I didn't eat before
attention gotta be the same thing we
made the same mistake I'm never drinking
again I would not play this again but
the good thing is I've done all that
stuff out of my system this is allows
you to see that everybody is human
everybody make the same common mistakes
and actually hopefully this will be a
start that we can begin to mend our
relationship you know I want to have
that relationship with you we can this
is great you know we usually don't sit
down and have candid conversations some
of these questions were really awkward
but I feel like it open it open up this
would be
this could be a new path for us you know
let's do it let's let's start because um
you know I have miss you okay I'm
anticipating motion
[Music]